the crossover sequel to Freddy versus
Jason took place in comic book form
titled Freddy versus Jason versus Ash
the six issue miniseries was published
in 2007 and written by James koric from
a story by Jeff Katz the writer of the
planned movie following that original
treatment more or less the story sees
Freddy resurrected by Jason through the
use of the Necronomicon at the same time
Ash Williams arrives in Crystal Lake
looking for the cursed book and an epic
battle ensues with Freddy resurrecting
all of Jason's previous victims as
deadites of ashma slay but what Mak
makes this sequel so unique is that it
even received a sequel of its own Freddy
versus Jason versus Ash the nightmare
Warriors published in 2009 and once
again written by koric based on a story
from cats this time around the US
government tries to control Freddy and
Jason's powers only to unleash them once
again on an unsuspecting populace then
it's up to Ash to join forces with
former survivors of both Madmen to bring
them down and save the world